also wir was wir wo wir uns alle einig
sind an diesem Tisch und wir reden über
einen gewaltiges Stromproblem in
Deutschland das obwohl ein großer Teil
der Regierung bis vor kurzem noch genau
das gesagt hat
wir haben einen Wärmeproblem bzw
industrieproblem aber kein Stromproblem
und wir haben gerade in Deutschland kein
Stromproblem wir haben ein Wärmeproblem
mit Blick auf diese Atomkraftwerke ist
der Punkt dass sie vor allen Dingen ja
zur Stromerzeugung da sind wir haben
derzeit aber kein Strom Problem sondern
wir haben einen gasproblem das heißt es
ist ja kein Selbstwert zu sagen wir
schließen Kohlekraftwerke oder wir
schließen Atomkraftwerke an sondern man
muss ja sagen warum wollen wir die
eigentlich wieder anschließen wir haben
keinen Strom Probleme mehr Klassen immer
wieder kam das den Sommer hinweg war das
dumm das zu sagen einfach Frau Bernburg
scheint nicht zu wissen dass Gas auch zu
Verstromung eingesetzt wird und bei uns
ja in den entscheidenden Umfang gerade
durch die letzten produziert der
Einheiten
im Sommer war das unverantwortlich es
war sach logisch nicht sehr kompetent
vor eigenen Käfer wie viel Menschen
kennen sie dieser Satz der bleibt ja im
Ohr den haben sehr viele Millionen
Deutsche wahrgenommen im Sommer immer
und immer wieder ja gesagt von einem
Teil der Regierung wie ich halte das
viele klug ich halte das nicht für klug
der natürlich wissen wir um die
Zusammenhänge zwischen Gaspreisen und
Strompreisen wir wissen um die
Unzulänglichkeiten der politischen
Rahmenbedingungen dazu wir Wissen darum
dass hin und her geredet wird zwischen
Bundesregierung und EU über die Bremsen
wie die ausgestaltet werden sollen über
die Frage der
übergewinnsteuer ist
Politik können sie helfen warum passiert
sowas
hin und her geschossen warum passiert
sowas warum passiert sowas warum sagt
die Politik ein Teil der Regierung im
Sommer wir haben kein Problem und da
wussten schon Millionen Deutsche Käfer
sagt das auch für sich
ich war auch zum damaligen Zeitpunkt
gegenteiliger Meinung und kann nur sagen
wir haben Laufzeiten der Kernkraftwerke
jetzt über den Winter verlängert und wir
haben eine strompreisbremse die kommt
mit Erlös Abschöpfung das was sie gerade
ja noch mal angesprochen haben also das
zeigt ja
alleine schon das zeigt ja alleine schon
dass wir beim Strom großen
Handlungsbedarf zu sehen
bewusst einmal nach ihren Kollegen und
Kollegen warum sagt man sowas in der
Politik wieder besseren Wissens und
gewisses will ich nicht drüber
spekulieren wahrscheinlich
das Thema weil das Thema unangenehm ist
es ging erfahren um die Laufzeiten der
Kernkraftwerke bei den Fragen unter weiß
doch jeder dass sich die Grünen damit
sehr sehr schwer getan haben und ich
vermute da könnte ein Zusammenhang
bestehen aber ich kann es auch nicht
sagen denn ich bin ja nicht bei den
Grünen sondern bei der evangel
Diskussion ganz ehrlich mit sie wissen
alles was im Hintergrund läuft seit wann
wissen Sie denn genau dass Deutschland
ein Stromproblem hat oder eins in diesem
Winter bekommt eine Energiekrise und die
bezieht sich auf alles auf das Strom auf
Heizöl auch jetzt auf Benzin ein
bisschen weniger in den letzten Wochen
aber wir haben im Grunde einen Energie
eine Energie der Krise und da hängt auch
alles mit allem am Ende zusammen und die
Ursachen sind fast immer auch die
gleichen also da würde ich jetzt nichts
ausklammern Kabinettstisch über
Blackouts gesprochen
es ist natürlich so dass wir uns auch im
Kabinett ich bin da nicht jede Woche
dabei immer nur in Vertretung aber das
selbstverständlich über die Sicherheit
der Stromversorgung gesprochen wird und
in der Tat beunruhigt mich auch wenn
Netzbetreiber wie zum Beispiel in
Baden-Württemberg Transnet Nachrichten
verschicken an Stromkunden bitte in der
Stunde nicht verbrauchen oder weniger
brauchen
Finanzministerium ganz konkret einen
Plan für ein Blackout gibt's Generatoren
beispielsweise im Finanzministerium
haben wir keinen Plan für Blackout das
muss das Wirtschaftsminister machen als
Energieministerium wenn das Licht aus
geht wenn der Aufzug nicht mehr fährt
Alter wir haben uns in der Tat auch mit
den Szenarien auseinandergesetzt ähm das
ist ganz klar das ist aber bei uns nun
auch relativ leicht zu lösen denn
schwierig wird es ja da wo Rettungswagen
raus müssen betroffen sind
von der Frage steht ja jeder Haushalt
haben sie Kerzen angeschafft im
Finanzministerium haben sie Generator
der
Finanzministerium angeschafft und auch
wenn Generator haben weiß ich nicht aber
wir sind natürlich in der Lage auch
mobil zu arbeiten also das ist
haben kommt doch überhaupt keiner mehr
bis in die City rein ich komme gleich zu
ihnen warum warum reden wir gerade diese
Woche oder warum müssen wir gerade diese
Woche so sehr über eine Blackout Gefahr
in Deutschland sprechen wir haben gehört
den Fall hat der Tonka gerade genannt
baden-württembergische Energieversorger
sagen also diese Woche wird es verdammt
eng so ab Mittwoch etwas was dann im
übrigen auch schon übermorgen ist da
fahren wir ab 14 mal lieber ab 14 Uhr
Nachmittag mal lieber ein bisschen
runter ja ich halte die Diskussion über
Blackouts für völlig unangebracht und
für falsch warum weil es keine Blackouts
geben wird in Deutschland ja wir müssen
mal definieren über was wir hier
sprechen sie sprachen gerade von dem
Strom Problem ja und das was die
Politiker gesagt hatten die ja
eingeblendet wurden war das Sprung
Stromproblem das ist mir zu pauschal was
heißt denn das das Stromproblem ja wir
haben alle ein Problem mit dem Preis das
haben wir eben diskutiert das ist ein
riesen Problem für einen Teil unserer
Bevölkerung und diesen Teil der
Bevölkerung nicht allen nicht die
Gießkanne sondern diesem Teil der
Bevölkerung muss die Politik helfen das
ist ein Phänomen mit den hohen Preisen
dass wir nicht auf Dauer haben werden
sondern das haben wir im Moment ja das
ist der einzige darüber haben
jetzt ist sprechen wir über die
Knappheit ja jetzt müssen wir ein
bisschen Begriffe lernen ja es gibt
Blackouts und es gibt Brown Outs ein
Blackout ist ein unkontrollierter
Ausfall eines großen Teils des
Stromnetzes sowas hat es noch nie in
Deutschland gegeben
heraus ein brown-out ist eine
kontrollierte Abschaltung kleinerer
Regionen für eine Stunde oder maximal 90
Minuten was im Voraus im Voraus
kommuniziert wird so entspannten Braunau
na das schalt mal meine Region ab Herr
Glasen ich glaube das also zwei Dinge
erstens die deutschen Stromnetze sind
zwar von ihrer Struktur die stabilsten
auf der erhält weil es ja auch sehr
dezentral sind
gleichwohl kann niemand vorhersagen was
bei bestimmten engpass-situationen
kommen wird weil das System zu komplex
ist zweiter Punkt Brown out sind
natürlich besser als Blackouts aber
fragen Sie mal bei Porsche oder Mercedes
oder VW was die sagen werden
kann für andere Industrie noch mehr
massive Folgewirkungen haben die ja weit
über den halben Produktionstag
hinausreichen also der die
Energiewirtschaft ist das zentrale
nervenschaft und dass wir als eine der
führenden Volkswirtschaften der Welt das
überhaupt heute diskutieren müssen ist
im Grunde erschreckend und Armutszeugnis
peinlich ein Stück weit sie sagen
guckt euch mal Porsche an wie die
anfangen werden dann sagen sie
wahrscheinlich na gut bei Porsche lassen
nein das sage ich überhaupt nicht er
Klassen hat ja recht und natürlich ist
das ein Armutszeugnis das Diskutieren
das liegt natürlich daran dass die
Politik schon zu Schröder Zeiten ja das
war nicht nur Merkel das ist fing schon
bei der SPD an sich viel zu sehr auf
Russland verlassen hat und viel zu sehr
an Russland gebunden hat
ich sehe das genauso wie sie aber wir
können es nicht mehr ändern
einigermaßen entspannt da müssen wir
halt einzelne Regionen vom Netz kurz
abhängen oder runterfahren
warum ich das entspannt sage auch ein
brown-out und da sind wir bei wieder bei
den den Zitaten aus der Politik von eben
die gesagt haben wir haben eher ein
Wärmeproblem als ein Stromproblem was im
übrigen kein Problem Mann was im übrigen
stimmt weil das Stromproblem was wir
haben kommt aus der Wärme ja und wir
haben die Diskussion auch um Brown aus
ist heute völlig unbegründet denn die
einz eine Chance dass wir oder Chance
das einzige Risiko vom Stromnetz das
einzige Risiko ein brownout in
Deutschland zu haben ist wenn die
Gasspeicher leer sind ja und das
passiert nur nach einem sehr kalten
Winter im Februar oder März
hängen sie ab ich glaube wenn wir zu der
Situation kommen die ich wie gesagt für
für überaus unwahrscheinlich halte dann
müssen wir
diskriminierungsfrei und und
der gerechteste weg ist dann alle
gleichermaßen abzuhängen ja
abgesehen natürlich von von von
Infrastruktur und von und von
Krankenhäusern und so weiter aber wir
könnten
beschäftigt sich gerade ganz konkret mit
der Frage Baden-Württemberg tut das ja
offenbar auch sonst hätte ich schon die
Meldung aufs Handy gegeben das heißt das
eine ganz konkrete Frage wenn wir
vorübergehend Blackout verhindern wollen
und dann eben kontrolliert runterfahren
bei wem eigentlich keinen Experte für
Netzstabilität aber ich habe gerade
heute gelesen dass das gar nicht möglich
ist irgendwie Adressen scharf
abzuschalten sondern das ist dann in der
Fläche gewissen ja in einem gewissen
Stadtteil oder möglich oder ist es nicht
möglich Sie können nicht sozialpolitisch
notfallpolitisch korrekt und scharf das
handhaben das ist in der Komplexität
unser Stromproblem kommt nicht aus dem
Wärmeproblem sondern unser Stromproblem
kommt aus der Gleichzeitigkeit von
Kernenergie Ausstieg Steinkohle Ausstieg
Braunkohle ausstieg und einseitigem
verlassen auf russischen Gas und erst
alle vier Dinge in Kombination haben das
möglich gemacht und es war mit Ansage
und es weil weil du immer wenn du nur
einen Kern Lieferanten für die
entscheidende Preis bestimmende Menge
hast und das ist kein Problem
mit Ansage sagen sie sind ein Mann der
Industrie was passiert eigentlich mit
Industrie mit ihrer mit ihrer mit
unserer Industrie was wird aus der
Industrie wie viele Menschen wie viele
Manager wie viel hoch dekorierte
Arbeiter kennen Sie die längst sagen das
hat hier keinen Sinn mehr in Deutschland
also ich brauche nur meine Erlebnisse in
der letzten zwei drei Tage anschauen
meine Tochter hat gestern 24 Stunden
gebraucht von Hannover nach Palma und
das hatte nichts mit dem Wetter zu tun
sondern nur mit dysfunktionalitäten bei
Lufthansa am Flughafen München
untereinander Stellen ich wollte am ich
bin England Fan wollte England
Frankreich sehen in einer Sportbar in
Braunschweig und konnte nicht mehr in
Sandwich bestellen weil die mir gesagt
haben wegen der Strompreise haben wir
die Küche zu gemacht wir sind dabei uns
aufgrund wesentlicher energiepolitischer
Fehler zu einem dysfunktionalen Land zu
entwickeln und damit verlieren wir an
dass die große Gefahr Respekt in der
Welt vieles von dem was wir sind können
und tun sind wir weil die Welt sehr viel
Respekt vor dem hat wie wir Dinge
gemacht haben und machen
also ja aber wenn der Ministerpräsident
von Baden-Württemberg die nicht als
Person sehr schätze allen sagt Denkmal
über den Waschlappen nach statt über die
Dusche selbst in Kambodscha und Laos
sind die Menschen heute gewohnt ein oder
zweimal am Tag übrigens auch als
Menschenrecht Duschen zu dürfen und wenn
wir allen Ernstes darüber nachdenken die
Menschen zu sagen ihr könnt nicht mehr
duschen weil wir euch die Energie nicht
mehr zu wettbewerbsfähigen Preisen zur
Verfügung stellen können nehmt lieber
den Waschlappen dann verlieren wir
Respekt in der Welt bitter böse Analyse
auch der Situation hier gerade in
Deutschland